[Music]
well i'm running
i'm running like my hand is on fire
and i don't
[Music]
september is the month i wait for all
year long it's when the weather cools
off the bugs calm down and the crowds
disappear the trails are melted out the
leaves start to turn and wild berries
are everywhere it's warm during the day
and chilly enough at night that you
bundle up and want a hot drink beneath
the stars if i could live in just one
month for the rest of my life it would
be september
washington is the last place i called
home before moving into my suv full time
and it was on these mountain trails and
forest roads that i fell in love with
living out of my vehicle and backpacking
every other night until the rain or snow
forced me south to warmer weather
[Music]
[Music]
for the past few weeks i've been based
around mount baker i've hiked a good
portion of the trails around here both
recently and over the past few years
there's no way to squeeze all those
trips into this one video but i thought
i'd start by sharing one from last week
and hopefully give you a glimpse into
one of my favorite places on earth with
some of my favorite people
[Music]
[Music]
on my soul please
please don't let it go
[Applause]
this is like
we gotta go up down up down some more
but we are heading
out there
never been there before
so we thought
that we were on the trail going straight
up there
but turns out we have to go all the way
down
and then back up again this is like the
fifth time we've had to do this
so
yeah it's a workout
it's pretty steep actually
scary yeah
it's kind of hard to see but this is
like a really steep drop
wish off could take your lips with me
on the road wherever i'd be i'd kiss you
good night
in a far off moonlight
i wish i could take your lips with me
listen to your little voicing
along with a radio
a song that someone else wrote but i
don't care
i just need you here
[Music]
wish i could take eyes with me
show you all the things i say
my favorite mexican bar
opening the big bright stars
[Music]
probably looking at some other man
seven gentlemen steal your hand but i'll
stand up
and i'll keep the mouth shut
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a carrot on there
so here's a back country hack
using the tripod
the little gold zero lantern
to create a little cooking area
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
i like to pull over
all packed up
ready to head out ready last night a
mouse got into my bag
new holes
his old hole from another mouse mouse
mouse
nice i can't talk
[Applause]
is there supposed to be an obvious trail
through here
so this trail that we're doing is not
heavily trafficked in fact we've only
seen one other group in the last two
days but um we're
trying to continue the trail and just do
a loop because getting here was kind of
gnarly a lot of up and downs like really
really steep grades
and we're not exactly sure if we're
going the right way we're using a trail
map and doing our best to follow that
but we're a little bit lost right now
and we're a little bit clipped out but
yeah stay tuned we're not sure if the
trail goes this way which goes straight
down
or this way
which also goes straight down
that way
it doesn't seem to be any visible trail
so we're just kind of scouting both
so we just climbed up
a really really steep ridge
lots of big boulders and small boulders
they were pretty easy to kick down it's
kind of
sketchy but uh
we're thinking that we found the trail
we're about to near the top so
we'll find out hopefully we don't have
to backtrack because that will be
no fun at all so here's where we just
came from
we were camped right there
we hiked all the way through
down into the gully and up
there's about baker
well i'm running
i'm running like my hands on fire
[Music]
okay so it's debatable how long we
actually hiked
somewhere between 10 and 14 miles but we
can be sure
that we got a good amount of elevation
gain that was quite the workout
we are in the mount baker wilderness we
just went on a hike and we are hiking
back to the car uh zivan and we are
going to
sweet potatoes sweet
potatoes
so many stairs
running
as is usually the case
running
to get my camera
in time
what will we do today
what will i do
[Music]
oh yeah good investment that seems extra
relevant nowadays
it's only a matter of time i think it's
already begun
at the condition every time
every time five
[Music]
nice of you to join us
we're on a mountaintop
[Laughter]